you know we had Eddie Bravo in on on the
on as a guest this past week and that
man he's keyed up
he's keyed up on life you know every
time you talk to him it seem like he's
on about a about a 8-ball of just
existence you know you ask him anything
and you know he just goes off
he's like a golden retriever with a
hearing problem and I'm saying he's off
he's gone you know I'm saying he's Kay
he's out there chasing invisible
frisbees you know he's out there chasing
a frisbee that was you know that just
topped out at about 20,000 feet and that
thing might not land until Idaho but
that's how Eddie Bravo is he's out there
he's out there and it was interesting to
hear a man I mean it was interesting
just if you didn't get to catch the
interview it was just interesting to
hear a man who had had who taken on so
many things in his life everything he
got into not only was he able to get
involved and really delve into a music
sports chasing ladies but he made it
into a business along the way so he was
able to take his passions and make them
into enough of a business where he was
able to sustain himself while he chased
individual dreams and that's I mean
that's that's amazing I mean that's
amazing to think that oh I like
something so I'm gonna make it you know
I'm gonna make my dream of a financially
sustainable reality while I chase it and
this dude was a straight-up dream hopper
Eddie Bravo is a dream hopper if you see
him on one dream tonight you better you
better circle the clouds because he
gonna be able to own another dream
tomorrow that man just goes dream the
dream he's out there just you know he's
out there just dreaming you know he's
just out there just just jumping from
one dream to the next and you know he
done he you know he tried football he
tried you know he tried music he got
into jiu-jitsu
you know now he's out there he's
thinking about outer space man his brain
his left earth and he's out there
chasing he's out there chasing what
could be next
dude get that [ __ ] a couple
months he'll build a shuttle and Eddie
Bravo will go looking for the truth and
is he a part time astronaut I don't know
but I bet he's got it in his in his DNA
I bet it should if you look into his DNA
I bet the a stands for Armstrong and the
N stands for Neil I bet he's got that D
Neil Armstrong in him cuz Eddie Bravo
you give him that chance boy he'll be
out there looking for the moon you give
that dude a couple pieces of siding and
some bubble gum and an old washer/dryer
bra that dude is I mean he's Latino to
the core he'll make the most out of
everything he don't miss a beat and he
about to turn that washa t know he's
about to turn that washing machine and
that two pieces of siding you know that
two-piece he's about to turn that into a
damn shuttle
you know viola El Bravo
in LA galaxy yeah but if you get a
chance check out that Eddie Bravo and it
was amazing to have him in studio and
just to it was just inspiring it was
inspiring to see somebody because what I
do is I'll get involved in something and
then I'll you know I won't i won't have
the the tenacity to also make it a
business while i am investigating it and
he just hopped it throughout his life
from one thing to the next I made small
business along the way made a band you
know made a juju start to learning Jiu
Jitsu next you know he's winning
champion he's beating the greatest in
other countries other countries think
about how many other countries there are
yeah so many and he Bravo was beating
people in other countries so if you got
to listen to that cool if you don't know
about it he Brava that's the thing is
he's a look he's like one of them cans
of um you ever get one of those cans of
snakes in the mail somebody send you a
can of snakes fake snakes and you think
oh it's just a can it's just praying
goals it's just chips you know about the
sour cream and onion myself down into a
straight up couch coma
and then your spouse er your you know
your your friend of your love when it's
going to come in you know a couple hours
later and found you just comatose and
some cushions but you open that can it's
not Pringles as fake snakes somebody
since you faked snakes come and they
popping out and NASA Eddie Bravo man you
ask him a question you take that top off
and you think it's going to be chips
you're gonna have one he's gonna have
one it's gonna be that convo but it's
just snakes boy just snakes flying out
of that beautiful man and look you know
anybody that can tempt the brain of Joe
Rogan for years decades even man I was
an honor to have him in studio and uh
and it was fun it was fun because you
know he talks a lot about outer space he
thinks out he thinks outer space is
fictional you know some when he looks up
at the stars it's like you and me just
looking at a painting you know he thinks
somebody did it and it's out there you
know it's like something that Microsoft
made or something and I don't I don't
disrespect it you know my original
thought is to think like ah you know
maybe that's crazy but is it crazy dude
I showed up here on a ball of dirt and
water and fell out I fell out of a
uterus bro a uterus something that's
hard to spell
I fell out of that into onto a ball of
dirt and water floating in the middle of
nowhere could anything be crazier than
that doubt si doubt si doubt see ya
ma'am I come out thanks for watching
that video right there that was a
beautiful little segment I think but of
course i'm partisan to myself but you
can move on to another video right now
you can check on this video or on this
video that's two different options and
you can also subscribe to the channel
check on a new video subscribe to the
channel check subscribers curse card